hey guys I'll be doing today I'm hanging
out with row hey you guys we're doing
something a little different today
yeah we are so I wanted to shoot some
videos today that will I can I bring my
Nintendo switch in qui play that
yes that's workable yes I'm so excited
for that if you love to have to play yes
okay I haven't had a chance to play but
I knew that you were playing and this is
how I knew because my phone went silent
for two days like I think in a text from
dressing or anything and you kind of
like disappeared off social media for a
minute and I was like okay either she's
really really sick
or one you're playing the new Zelda game
both of those and it was both of those
at the same time I'm pretty good at
writing back to text and I even realized
I didn't write back to Facebook as well
I'm the worst so we're not going to be
playing Zelda today because it's a
one-person game and I'm just very
invested so I can't share about the love
but what I plan shares we've got one to
switch and we've got snipper clips okay
I've not played either of these I'm just
really excited I want to play these I'm
sorry it seems you will play the one to
switch there's like a cow milking game
you can you know these you can there's
just a bunch of random things on it and
you know there's no point even trying to
explain it it's kind of like charades is
what you're saying yeah I mean that sort
of so something's I haven't actually
played yet so some of them you sit down
okay others you got to get up and get
real rowdy okay I'm ready so let's do
something where we sit down this is a
nice little intro I think to the whole
game okay for like a beginner this is
called ball count to Anjali Khanna
ballroom vibrate I'm having a box with
balls roaming around inside into the joy
Khan's
and no path right so you're going to try
to figure out how many marbles were in
the box I'm going to give you that one
okay
is it good is it going this well if you
could wall and write the cue ball is
rolling around something help if you
just put it in one hand oh my gosh this
is so weird
I feels like very Marvel play now okay I
think I know
okay would calm down once you meet hum
okay there okay okay I'm going to set it
down
okay I'm gonna guess what about you how
many you think's in there I guess the
same thing
thank you also the answer is
oh ok ok these are there was two it felt
like threes I felt like a boy hurt
Sigmund like it ok yes well ok mmm ok I
made my gas you've made you get maybe
I'll be right this time
no I'm not I don't Sharon oh no little
vanilla
ok I'm not God weird ok I got it I'm not
I'm not gonna go I think we should
problems milk as well cacao and even
milk the cow before once I'm like a
class field trip
hey this was a long time ago this was
like more than 15 years ago
we'll think back to what that was like
if does it have sensory vomit you'll
feel the milk yeah what responders in
case you get real while ok
yeah thanks he knows me we're locked
loaded and ready hates about honor
ok for some cow letters car their bottom
ok hot bottom yep sure to sweet top bono
you'll get a gamma-ray to your channel
yeah yeah ok
my first time milk I got was two cups
wow person win lose I thought we're
doing the same thing
fill it up look at your hands when you
melt I'm finally right in remember this
is a yes okay he's going to make you
faster yeah let's try we're no more no
more muffin top
oh I think my sensors it's lovely
Jesse I'm so impressed Wow
biggest improvement I've ever had that's
incredible look at our record now and a
new record records my entire system so
we rolled it on to I'm like you just
dominated the milking game hmm let's see
sneaky dice signal time
do you want to shave yes okay oh look at
these guys they're getting ready so
that's going to be honest they're
shaving yeah oh we're practicing oh uh
I'm using some silly because a prefix
isn't okay okay I've had to shave off my
eyebrows all that was I think I just
missed my eyelash you're yet you're I
like my long time this evening it has a
camera in here it could be that one does
have a camera well you probably seen my
face yeah
how'd we do oh wow Wow do you have one
percent yeah music music - Wow
oh here's the replay oh wow I was not
going to be real careful over there
Oh baby oh this is to see if you can
cool a baby this is weird
you know no I'm a dog I don't want it I
really don't either home being con okay
yes yes yes yes you put in your mouth
kind of basically just poured it into
exactly what the students doing and
we're eating hoping I'll be your coach
okay I'll be the finish I'm ready ready
so who's your head don't move anything
just your mouth
one two three nine when forth alone
whatever I'm pretty good do you want try
yeah okay we can code to me yes okay let
me know when it's ready
actually I'm sired do you play families
will be there when you're ready and we
did you happen in a half then you owe me
Oh Manny how many so many top eight air
guitars dance is really long oh my
goodness creepy chicken choker okay
I mean I guess we'll try it maybe we can
fake it out like yeah maybe a spinner I
actually have to hit ourselves that hard
I think in all visits motion sensor
should we stand out I feel like should
we are we lazy gorilla maybe we are as
much little bit of little hands in the
air like a gorilla move your arms in the
air like a gorilla in your arms oh sure
- oh you actually hit yourself alright
but don't actually found it so actually
damn it
almost Arneson well I'm exhausted
thank you oh please oh oh look at her 9r
injury okay let's do this quick draw
this one well I think we can do
oh I'm already Western Maddie you like
westerns look at a location I do too
this is to remind me of West world would
I be a black hat or a white hat and I
would like that yeah I probably start
off as white at and then somewhere
around and along the line I feel like
I'm in black hat now how did you do that
laughter I don't know it's so funny
when you have a standoff like back in
the Western times like Oh Freddie
she's a did I get shot
nice shootin Tex no universe is I guess
what I'm listening for it because as
soon as they say fire you got to do like
shooting me ha ha do you mean some I
mean I live in here did you not I don't
think I didn't even fire right look at
the replay I didn't even fire her I
think maybe yeah you know it'll feel try
it again
Justine for me to really get this I feel
like we need to do it how they really do
it I'm gonna do a start back-to-back
like there's a western movie okay and
then you got to walk look you might have
a good walk it's just do baby steps
I'm gonna just do like three baby steps
1 2 3 go
down and down I'll pretend I knew best
turn directions I just shot my slim I
just shot my heart oh sorry your foot
off for your Adrienne yours okay it's
alright
oh my goodness this is not a good cowboy
I mean I opened a tooth powder I think I
shot your foot again okay I go to shoot
the third table tennis yeah we need to
like back up a little more okay oh then
you go over here okay
we took you back we'll just wrap it up
soon up okay so just picture the table
here your surroundings and stand far
enough apart so you don't bump in hand
and for each other yeah oh except in
that way this swing and hit the ball as
it comes down it doesn't either the ball
or you can hit it's like oh the Bible is
not real oh oh I miss I was too so sorry
I didn't see it
yeah I guess it's right there here let's
do it about the man to top okay just
make believe you got this
I've got a picture the divorce and is
here
Oh Oh your service
[Applause]
well it's a long game here yes table
tennis champion right here
milking champion destroyed I'm not good
at virtual ball you just pretended there
but it's not there like I mean didn't
you one last no yeah okay listen I I
have to just give lease how bad it was a
quick draw I'm gonna shooting my feet
off okay I'm ready I'm ready all right
okay week on InTouch me an L and an R
button look like nobody's help you feel
about that I don't know was crazy I
finally think so I finally figure out
don't let go of the top button just
abano bonbon you want a long Pete
over there it's really long it's like
feet long it's like two feet long
there's a really big challenges yeah
what do you think awesome yeah what you
think Mandy he's not watching you play
bells
I can play imaginary table tennis and I
can milk I can milk a cow only thing my
logic which I loved it oh my gosh I love
that these games are so I don't creative
I've never played video games like this
no it's weird because they kind of
change the game like you're it's more
interactive being real life like they
don't want you to look at the screen
which is kind of strange if you keep
wanting to look at it that's why did the
whole cake so a whole time we're playing
I keep trying to look at this screen but
you're not supposed to you're just look
to listen because they're like victim a
TAS and go with it and they yell at you
every time it looks like a no they know
how to do they can see if you're looking
over there but I'm like are they doing
it we need to play more of these and
wonders which easier than sniffer clips
or am I getting way
different clips want to play that in a
whole nother video because it takes a
while to get started but it's super fun
like you it's a team-based game so you
can actually play up to four players
okay that could even be fun if we get
like oil yeah it's super fun I mean
there's not many games out right now so
hopefully by the end of the year they'll
be more fun stuff to play and really I
loved it just seen it thank you for
bringing over online games this was so
much fun I ride one to switch it's fun I
definitely have some favorite games
within one two three oh there's some
more because the girl was too hard that
was so hard there's one where you like
chase a flag to the beach so just a lot
of moving and running so I was like well
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this you want to
see more one two switch or us do
anything I don't know you guys always
have some really fun suggestions for
some collabs yeah speaking up we also
did one on Rose channel so I'm going to
check that out and also all of her links
and everything in the description below
and annotations somewhere I don't know
where I put them they're always
different every time they appear maybe
there you may enjoy a beer will be right
where I'm gonna hop
[Music]
[Applause]
that's why didn't you locate so they
just kind of like there's nothing cuter
than a little baby chicken I'm just like
[Laughter]
there's a weird if you played this a
local male